E aí
[Música]
se você já se sentiu inadequado por ser
quem você é em algum momento da vida
acho que muita gente pode ter passado
por esse é um momento de repente na
escola por ter cabelo cacheado ou por
ser gordinho talvez por ser um pouquinho
mais baixo nos colegas a classe eu então
quando os seios começam a aparecer
muita gente não sente saudade dessa
época agora imagina você quer sentimento
de inadequação fosse permanente
para toda a sua história que ser quem
você é fosse um problema para algumas
pessoas que você sentisse medo de sentir
100% você para um chefe ou por alguém da
sua própria família talvez possam te
demitir ela não te convidar mais para o
Natal
e já pensou se alguém te falasse que a
sua existência fosse um pecado um erro
nojo que existissem pessoas que os assim
como desculpa Deus ou então até mesmo
uma religião para minimizar quando
alguém fala mal ou fala que você é uma
aberração
Você já parou para pensar se você é uma
pessoa normal
eu já pensei muito eu sou gay nasce uma
família extremamente conservadora a
religião em casa era protestante então
eu cresci ouvindo coisas bem pesada
sobre o pessoas que eram iguais a mim
a sensação de adequação e conforto sobre
Cê quem eu era demorou muito para chegar
lá pelo tempo da faculdade
e num primeiro momento antes que eu
pudesse perceber qualquer coisa e
perguntava porque eu quebrava a mão ou
falava fino às vezes de forma até
violenta fala que nem homem para descer
Maricá e o processo da homofobia se
inicia antes mesmo de você se perceber
gay é muito louco isso esse processo é
super pesado Depois vieram os meus
próprios questionamentos a por quê que
eu acho bonitinho outros meninos mas não
acha as meninas como eu faço para mudar
isso Será que é possível mudar isso não
não é
e tem quem quer te pegar na saída do
colégio tem que me te olhar torto dentro
da igreja e tem quem é muito amigo quer
te ver bem e tenta erroneamente entender
para você ser uma pessoa firme macho
depois de um tempo eu tive recursos para
entender quem eu sou entender os outros
e me amar não é todo mundo que tem a
mesma sorte tem quem passa uma
existência inteira lutando contra si
mesmo para quem LGBT por mais bem
resolvido que você seja com suas
questões sempre tem um momento muito
angustiante que é um ambiente de
trabalho
há 16 anos no meu primeiro emprego bem
novinho comecei a trabalhar como
atendente numa rede de fast-food é uma
rede que tava chegando no Brasil então
não tinha loja em Campinas onde eu
morava eu tinha que ir para São Paulo no
shopping no Morumbi todos os dias foi
muito legal lembro com muito carinho
uma vez que eu era meu primeiro emprego
primeiro bateu o dedo a INSS toda essa
circunstância eu tava muito feliz por
isso
e no último dos dez dias de Treinamento
eu tava muito contente e na saída eu
pedi para tirar foto com o gerente da
loja com as meninas que me ajudaram a
treinar
o gerente que não tinha nem 20 anos de
idade começou a rir com os colegas dele
ele falava que não queria tirar foto Os
colegas dele falaram para olhar vai
tirar foto com as meninas
naquele momento eu sentia homofobia pela
primeira vez no trabalho
bom E era apenas o começo de uma jornada
muito grande que eu ainda teria que me
entender comunguei com os paradigmas com
a família sociedade e por fim Claro um
corporativismo
último nível de armário para LGBT é o
trabalho é comum LGBT esconder a sua
sexualidade no trabalho por inúmeros
fatores por preconceito dos trabalhos e
chefe perda de oportunidade por conta da
sua sexualidade
violência psicológica e o medo de ficar
desempregado você demitido para algumas
pessoas saem do armário no trabalho e na
vida aí como se você saísse de um lugar
de Privilégio de um lugar confortável e
fosse para um lugar perigoso
ter que lidar com circunstâncias que
você não precisaria lidar até então se
você não tivesse que ter essa escolha
Agora imagina que você que não LDB ter
que está assistindo e tivesse que mudar
o nome do seu esposo ou da sua esposa
por medo eu tenho colegas que e a gente
muito mais feliz quando a gente é que
nós podemos ser
Olá eu sou formado em administração fiz
pós em marketing estratégico e gestão de
projetos eu me preparei para uma
carreira consolidada e corporativismo
mesmo eu ainda tenho muita coisa para
realizar muitos sonhos para vencer Mas
mesmo com todo apoio das da Família com
a minha sexualidade bem entendida eu
tive coragem de sair do armário só uns
dois anos atrás
e eu não sei se é são uma pesquisa da o
final realizada aqui no Brasil nos
revela que 61 por cento dos
profissionais lgbts escondem sua
sexualidade no trabalho
a 41 por cento dos gays afirmam ter
sofrido algum tipo de discriminação no
trabalho por conta da sua orientação
sexual
33% nas empresas brasileiras não
contratariam pessoas lgbts para cargos
de liderança
e é muito casado pensar nesses números
como uma realidade para você não é mesmo
e eu Paulo ela falou numa posição
extremamente confortável e comparação
com outras pessoas eu sou o homem não
negro esses Ou seja eu nasci e me
entendo por homem desde sempre agora
imagina imaginemos outras pessoas por
exemplo mulheres que sofrem terríveis
violências nas empresas
transexuais pessoas negras imagina o
desafio de uma mulher transa Negra por
exemplo e isso infelizmente não é força
de expressão uma estimativa realizada
pelo antral Associação Nacional das
travestis e transexuais aqui no Brasil
nos afirmam que noventa porcento das
pessoas trans no Brasil recorre à
prostituição em algum momento da vida
por falta de oportunidade que as pessoas
não querem contratar por preconceito Eu
tenho um amigo que tem uma família algum
afetiva formada e o chefe dele nem sabe
tem nos e ele é de fato porque a
masculinidade tóxica no mente dele não
permite que você
seja gay e ainda assim gosta de futebol
e fale de igual com os outros caras
Porque o fato de você se relacionar com
uma pessoa do mesmo sexo pode gerar essa
quebra de conexão com algumas pessoas
isso ainda é uma questão pra muito
gestores ela não perder as oportunidades
e networking relacionamento rap hour
esse meu conhecido se submete nessa
posição
e eu tive nessa situação dois anos é
confortável não está na situação talvez
por medo inconsciente eu não sei era um
fardo não necessário e que bobagem eu
tenho que eu lembro que na época eu
tinha um assistente que ele também por
acaso era gay em uma reunião para
aprovação de uma campanha publicitária
um dos meus cheques não gostou de uma
peça que eram dois rapazes de sunga uma
boia de piscina não tem nada demais mas
para ele aquilo era coisa de era
degradante ao tentar defender a campanha
falei que isso não era um problema
inclusive LGBT nativos financeiramente
possuem quatro vezes mais poder de
consumo
e pago impostos não fazem mal a ninguém
o meu assistente é mandou na lata ou
fala é gay é uma pessoa normal
trabalhadora fui consumidores a besteira
fofinho a campanha não foi aprovada e eu
saí muito bravo com o meu acidente
aquele dia ali ele me falou a coisa mais
poderosa que eu poderia ter ouvido no
trabalho Abrir inteira você tem vergonha
de quem você é foi muito pesado no dia
me ver uma posição homofóbica logo eu
olhei ali eu percebi que não adiantava
apenas deve estar confortável não
adianta a construir uma carreira
consolidada me sentar de um super
problema social que é de todo mundo que
inclusive o estou inserido nele e fingir
normalidade não ter a sensibilidade
humildade de olhar para trás se assumir
no seu trabalho é um ato político porque
eu não vi LGBT nos ambientes
corporativos que eu estava o fato de
sermos quem somos no nosso trabalho
visibiliza que existimos o nosso
sentimento que podemos ser quem somos e
temos a carreira dos sonhos correr atrás
do que queremos que é possível sim ser o
que quisermos sem ter que se esconder
sem se sentir inadequado como aquele
garoto eu me sentia super novinho era
demeter trabalham CD de gestão crescem
na carreira ganham dinheiro
consomem e devem ser respeitados
independente de qualquer coisa temos
famílias temos sonhos temos poder de
consumo temos fé nós existimos
gestores mesmo que você não seja LGBT
precisamos dar oportunidade para todas
as pessoas
entender que o ser humano é plural uma
empresa que entrega e dá oportunidades
para mulheres negros lgbts perceber se
torna-se uma empresa com a visão 360°
isso é muito poderoso todo mundo ganha
com números tão alarmantes
principalmente relacionados à mulheres e
trans nós precisamos tomar a
responsabilidade
e existem talentos de todas as formas
ser quem somos é algo poderoso ser LGBT
que ia mais no seu mente de trabalho é
algo poderoso porque quando eu assumo um
lugar de liderança assumo que eu sou gay
em algum lugar onde eu pertenço um lugar
onde algumas pessoas acreditam que eu
não deveria pertencer E isso se torna
potente isso transforma a sociedade
encoraje os meus iguais e quebra
estigmas preconceituosos isso torna a
sociedade um lugar melhor é uma
sociedade mais inclusiva
sair do armário no trabalho é um ato
político
contratar pessoas lgbts para diversas
frentes é um ato político de
potencialização da sociedade
principalmente de amor ao próximo
Muito obrigado a
[Música]
E aí